welcome back this is episode 2 of my
four-part series where I take a look
back at Dragon Ball GT to see if it's
worthy of all the criticism that's
received since it was released in 1996
last week's video was it could have gone
better but it's a new week and that
means a fresh start and according to
both people that really like Dragon Ball
GT that's a joke
I'm joking this could very well be the
best saga of the entire series I'll of
course talking about the baby saga this
saga chronicles two separate story
sequences one covering Gil's supposed
betrayal of our heroes and the Tuffle
engineered parasite known as baby which
on its own sounds to me like an
exceptionally fun concept for a story
and since last week's video covered a
saga that can be summed up as the gang
looking around for Dragon Balls while
spending most of their time not looking
for Dragon Balls because and needless to
say I am decently excited for this this
week of the covering episode 17 to 40
this is Dragon Ball GT the baby saga
last week our story ended as Gil's
seemingly betrayed Goku trunks and
panned by leading them to his homeworld
where he seems to be heralded as some
sort of hero as a key member among the
ranks of general ruled Oh a subordinate
of dr. mu has a nice change of pace Goku
and trunks get kidnapped per Gil's
instructions leaving pan alone to figure
out some sort of plan to fix this
horrible situation honestly it's not a
terrible cliffhanger and now that we're
all caught up let's go alrighty so this
entire 23 long group of episodes I'll be
watching can be split into two separate
stories the first acting is a sort of
setup to the narrative that follows but
that's not to say that this first half
can stand on its own and isn't
entertaining in its own right that's
right
if you thought I was here just a ragged
GT then I've got news for you I actually
like this part I am NOT going to nor
have I ever pretended to like or dislike
something simply because it's a popular
opinion I just share my own opinions as
I have them win lose or draw but on this
occasion I actually really like this
part now that's not to say I think it's
perfect and I most definitely have my
issues with it but compared to the first
act it's like ultra instinct William
Shakespeare right off the bat the story
establishes who the point-of-view
character will be what the goal is and
what pan needs to do this is
advantageous because now that all of
that is understood by the viewer you're
now free to have fun finding wacky ways
for Patton to infiltrate the compound
that holes are grandpa and Trunks and
those antics are very fun sneaking
around little bits of action here and
there with plenty of characters shining
through this is GT honestly it's best
for me and it was nice seeing pan earned
a win for a change - she eventually
finds her way into the main chamber the
others are being held also finding
trouble for herself however in doing so
inspires Goku to free himself the next
episode doesn't really offer much it's
essentially a fighting heavy episode
following Goku as he dismantles the
forces of general rildo despite not much
happening narrative Li it's clear that
this episode and arc is following a very
different story philosophy than the
original 16 that I reviewed in part 1
the next episode is worth things reduced
have to kick off however with some
beautiful artwork capturing Goku's first
altercation with general rildo
and pans attempts to reclaim trunks whom
time looks as though he's been frozen in
carbonite lots of Star Wars influence in
this arkin now that I think about it pan
even got stuck in a trash compactor in
the earlier episode speaking of which I
should also mention while in that trash
compactor she met a friendly pink alien
robot this will be important later the
fight itself between general rule doe
and Goku is actually quite good lots of
imaginative choreography and angles are
implemented things however at this time
don't look great for trunks who has been
just transported to dr. muse laboratory
as the story continues Goku continues
his battle with general rule though
eventually gaining the upper hand before
rildo reveals that he is the actual
planet they are on very reminiscent of
the Dragon Ball Z movie the return of
Kuler while this is all happening pan
continues in her attempts at
infiltrating the compound to rescue
trunks but without a means of
teleportation to dr. mew pan is fighting
a losing battle
however she manages to run into her
friend from the trash compactor she
helped escape who offers to help her in
this endeavor
with some difficulty they managed to
barge into the complex but are quickly
surrounded once again however not one to
go quietly pan begins charging her
kamehameha aiming it right at Gill and
an army of robots at the last second
guild teleports her back to the front
door once again only this time with the
Dragon Balls we quickly switch back to
the fight between general rildo and Goku
as it rages on in various interesting
locations until pad rushes into the
battles towing Goku that she has the
Dragon Balls rildo uses this distraction
as an opportunity to turn both pad and
Goku into Carbonite teleporting them
both to dr. mu also up until now Kim has
been helping the forces of dr. mu and
general though in their efforts to
capture the Saiyans and obtain the
Dragon Balls however suddenly gill
unfreezes pan and cook who were really
his traitors actions in the past had
been a ruse in order to get the guys
closer to dr. mu trunks reveals himself
to be in perfect health and to have been
in on it the entire time orchestrating
this plan along with Gil in order to
tamper width and destroy whatever dr.
Mia was working I'm not sure if I'm a
fan personally of this swerve the story
attempted to pull off while it was
indeed surprising it's not surprising
because it cleverly concealed the true
nature of trunks and guild by means of
well-structured writing no it did so by
not giving any clues at all aside from
Gil giving pan the Dragon Balls an
episode prior supply
like this work best when it makes the
audience say to themselves oh of course
it all makes sense no even going back to
the first episode of this season this
didn't do that for me it's just a reveal
of another piece of information I
couldn't have predicted based on what
the story demonstrated so far to me that
said I don't dislike it really it's just
not what I was hoping for
after this grind revealed Trunks leads
the gang into this excessive
unnecessarily massive chamber housing an
engineered parasite known as baby while
he floats there like a good boy trunks
reveals that he took the initiative
while everyone was distracted to disarm
the situation by halting baby's
development and life by way of computer
virus this however does not stop dr. Mew
from going full psycho trying to revive
the artificial creation walls seeming
futile his efforts do bear fruit baby
lives
exploding forth from his tank but has
quickly taken out by Goku pan and trunks
it looks over but baby is not done as
the gang tries to escape the planet baby
attempts to stop them through general
rill doze body the episode ends with
baby revealing that he designed dr. Mew
which to me honestly sounds like it
makes as much sense as performing brain
surgery on yourself this isn't the last
time we see baby though following this
there's a collection of two episodes
following the gang as they stumble
across a spaceship wreckage holding
within it a Dragonball
however after arriving gills senses a
life-form on board an unconscious young
child they quickly transport the child
to a planet for aid where it's revealed
that he and the rest of the ship he came
from had been eliminated by baby
now dwelling within the young child he
attempts to take over trunks his body
but ultimately fails in doing so because
he lacked the strength it's at this
point I thought the story was gonna go
downhill but it actually takes a major
upswing
we hired cut to earth and we are
reintroduced to Goten and his family I
love goat ends knew all about the ladies
and date character he still holds a
pleasant personality but with that quirk
it adds some comedy and edge to him that
I really enjoy while I was on a date he
encounters a number of individuals who
have come under baby's influence he's
made it to earth while the gang were out
gathering the remaining Dragon Balls the
fight between baby and Gotha is honestly
interesting with Goten showcasing some
of his fantastic new personality however
he ultimately falls as baby infiltrates
his body at this point baby's ultimate
goal is to possess Vegeta's body the
strongest fighter on
so he worked his way up the pecking
order securing Gohan's body also in this
episode once baby takes ahold of Gohan
he makes a beeline for vegeta who at
this time is on his way back from the
store with his daughter bra a wonderful
side effect a baby's character that
hasn't been seen before is that it
forces interesting matchups we wouldn't
expect to see normally an interesting
rematch - between Vegeta and go Han who
haven't fought really since he was a kid
with in this episode it's revealed that
baby can influence the minds of those he
was once within it's also explained that
he's a toughie creation and Vegeta
recognizes him the fight between the two
is honestly quite fun with nice
animation in places
additionally the scene works very
naturally for exposition - which is
always a plus baby is an engineered
Tuffle parasite with the former Tuffle
rulers DNA embedded within it he can lay
eggs in his former host to maintain
control over them and his goal is to
take revenge on the Saiyan race that
destroyed and stole his homeworld and to
rule the universe because of course it
is while all this horrible this is
happening on earth we switch back to the
gang in space as they finally retrieved
the last of the Dragon Balls once they
arrived back home it's revealed to us
but not Goku pan and trunks that the
earth has been totally overrun by baby
and his minions before the gang goes
their separate ways to their respective
homes to give the Dragon Balls to a
possessed Dende and Patents says her
goodbyes to kill by tying her bandanna
around the smaller robot while this is
all happening as a quick aside Satan had
the ingenious idea of hiding inside
majin buu i absolutely love that majin
buu is immune and it makes complete
sense very clever
once Goku and pad arrive home they are
ambushed by Bebe's minions but trunks is
ambushed specifically had much more of
an emotional weight behind it I think as
Vegeta lures trunks into the house gills
sensors are going off Danger Danger he
says as baby Vegeta reveals his true
intent Gill beats him and trunks to the
punch with some missiles catching baby
off guard protecting trunks as baby
begins talking trash insulting and
threatening the small robot to stand
down killed without hesitation reloads
his missiles compared to pretty much
everyone in this series Gill is
outmatched
he knows that that's what makes this
scene so powerful for me and I actually
got emotional when baby took him out in
the end and it's not over that great
scene is immediately followed by the
single best reveal of the arc and this
arc has a few great reveals still to
come baby it turns out had control over
trunks this entire time
he didn't activate him until he brought
the balls back which is incredibly smart
of him baby and an exceptionally well
delivered swerve by the writers it makes
complete sense from both mechanical and
motivational points of view we then
switch back to Goku situation as the
fight rages on between himself and Gohan
when out of nowhere
Goten tries to blindside him this
however is not a problem for Goku as he
blocks the blast without even looking
Goku is much more serious in this arc
which I'm honestly really happy about
Satan uses this lonely action to fill
Goku in and what's happened every
character is now up to speed and the
pieces are in place here's hoping they
can stick the landing
what follows is Goku's first encounter
with baby Vegeta and bad news he can't
maintain Super Saiyan 3 because of his
infant body baby on the other hand can
absorb his servents power draining the
energy from Goten Gohan and trunks I
sincerely thought baby Vegeta's design
looked much more intimidating before
this power absorption however this is
the start of a trend unfortunately as
baby gets stronger his appearance goes
from looking like an intimidating
infected version of Vegeta to something
that's far less interesting in terms of
design and are overly complex and
definitely something that takes away
from the action for me with that said
baby easily defeats Goku meanwhile
Panama star Satan are safe for now
thanks to boos powers baby then retires
to his throne where he uses the Dragon
Balls to wish for his home planet to be
recreated this is where some weird stuff
starts to happen but honestly I'm sort
of into it Goku finds himself sort of
stuck in another dimension I was worried
it was a complete deus ex machina but it
turns out that the supreme kai made a
save on Goku at the last possible second
before he was defeated by baby it's
actually a quite a clever idea using the
Kai's instantaneous movement during this
Goku ends up falling into another
dimension with his only means of escape
being a decisive defeat of this
character in a dangerous board game it's
silly but I enjoy for the same reasons I
enjoy snake ways antics Goku has
difficulty initially but finds out that
that's because the other guy is an
absent
sheet was this characters cheating is
exposed the game itself begins to fall
apart and Goku manages to escape the
dimension randomly appearing in a random
part of the universe was the supreme kai
senses his energy he plucks Goku and the
folks he rescued from the random part of
space back to safety I really like this
and to be honest I've really enjoyed how
the story has been structured so far
it's paced well baby has an interesting
power with a perfect motivation the
stakes feel massive and most importantly
they are doing a great job at delivering
surprises without breaking the
established rules and logic of the
Dragon Ball world it's honestly very
impressive after this Goku begins his
training on the world of the Kai's while
this is all happening panic for grandpa
and Buu devised a plan but in order to
enact this scheme that involves
laxatives they make their way to baby's
new planet in order to get close to him
and find more trouble than they
bargained for they're all attacked and
white as pan was about to be choked out
by her father
ooop makes the save awesome this AK is
so crazy
ooop fights baby but quickly loses
however during this Buu feels a
connection to who he brings segment pan
to safety and says his goodbyes rushing
in to make the save Anup reuniting with
him honestly a really nice full circle
moment for majin buu and much better
than what he got in Dragon Ball super
baby resumed his fight against booth
while this is happening the khayat's are
in the middle of trying to regrow Goku's
tail the contrast of this epic
versus baby fight with Goku having
pliers on his butt is hilarious who
makes a misstep however turning himself
into chocolate instead of baby
Goku now with his tail regrown rejoins
the action to fight baby he goes super
saiyan 3 from the start but has quickly
defeated lying in a heap he begins
staring at earth for calling his life
there suddenly Goku begins transforming
into a golden whose honour I have an
issue with this earth acting as a
substitute for the moon is weird and I
really don't like it naturally Goku has
no control as the Azzaro but pan helps
Goku regain control by showing him a
picture of when she was little with him
it's pretty touching immediately he
begins transforming into Super Saiyan 4
I don't think I need to say this but
it's an awesome design and it's
tailor-made for the baby saga you are
coy at dis Conda
it's not looking good for the parasite
but in a matter of seconds a baby
mind-controlled Bulma pulls a machine
out of her butt that harnesses the
Earth's blood slaves and fires that baby
who has no tail this is a real bad case
of wanting the fight to be a certain
specific way but not having the first
clue of how to get it there without
breaking a number of rules which is a
shame because it was so consistent
before this baby begins to transform
into a golden Lazaro on the bright side
they have a built-in excuse for baby to
be able to control this form Vegeta
knows how to and so therefore baby can
take advantage of that there's also a
nice shot where Goku Stan's literally
between the earth and its destruction as
baby fires a super Galaga
Goku manages to block the massive blast
however baby has lost his senses
becoming what he hates the most an
out-of-control monster both baby and
Goku lying motionless completely sapped
of their energy while this is all
happening the Kai's devise a plan to use
the sacred water from the garlic Junior
arc of Z of all things to free those
under baby's control it's a cute idea
and I actually kind of like it using
this water trunks is free from baby's
control and is tasked with finishing off
baby
however Bulma still under baby's control
fires more [ __ ] I mean blood sways
at baby this for some reason fully
energizes him and Goku staggers to his
feet once again while Goku is on the
brink and with pan in danger trunks
sends a blast knocking over baby
go on goat and the others also come to
Goku's rescue having been freed from
baby's control thanks to the sacred
water Goku requests that everyone give
him their power but baby doesn't give
him enough time suddenly something
begins happening to baby
it's ooh and he's alive inside of him
apparently he changed the chocolate on
purpose to get the jump on baby from the
inside
Goku uses this time to absorb the
other's energy to replenish his own they
continue to fight with baby for an
episode and Goku blasts off his tail but
I thought I didn't need the tail with
the blood slaves as Vegeta's body
reverts to normal size baby for some
reason remains gigantic within him
despite him being malleable for the
entire arc this is honestly a terrible
way to keep Vegeta alive while removing
baby from his body also I guess baby
didn't lay eggs inside Vegeta either as
a last-ditch effort baby tries to escape
in his spaceship but Goku stops and by
blasting him into the Sun they then
returned the earth to normal by
spreading the sacred water but since the
Dragon Balls were not brought back in
time the earth
explodes along with piccolo who decided
to stay behind on earth as it exploded
he did this in order to get rid of the
Dragon Balls because he believes that
they cause more harm than good and just
like that piccolo and the earth are gone
the story ends as they used in Amenti
and Dragon Balls to restore the earth
and everything back to normal this was
much much much more enjoyable than the
first act in fact that's an
understatement
from the very beginning it was obvious
that there was a much clearer vision and
goal for this story and because it
focused more in action with sprinkles of
adventure it felt like a much more
natural continuation on from Dragon Ball
Z I also really like the idea of baby
being a parasite using his vote to help
him mature and take control I also
enjoyed his origin and motivation
watching him slowly slip and turn into
exactly what he hated most of all for an
invader mindlessly destroying other
planets and even his own in the name of
his race there were also plenty of
wonderful character moments - through
Gill pan majin buu and even Goten I also
really liked that Super Saiyan 4 allowed
Goku to be an adult what are my biggest
gripes with Goku getting turned into a
kid was how his character models stunted
and negatively impacted all the fights
he took part in a curatorial change Goku
into an adult so that he could make use
of his longer limbs as Dragonball focus
more and more on fighting stumpy limbs
don't offer much in the way of
interesting posing despite making his
kid self and GT skinnier than the
original appearance was now that Super
Saiyan 4 exists within the story goku
could enjoy the best of both worlds
doing all the lighthearted stuff a kid
would but when he gets serious it's
adult time and finally the story managed
to pull off some wonderfully written
surprises - whether it being through
trunks his body being under the control
of baby the entire time Buu housing pan
and mr. Satan safely or making the save
on more than one occasion with all of
that said I think this arc still had
some major problems the swarm of trumps
and Gil being in cahoots at the
beginning of the arc doesn't really land
like I would have liked
additionally general rildo isn't
defeated he just sort of becomes
irrelevant also I didn't like the earth
being used as a blocks wave source and
Bulma creating a blood suede amplifier
in minutes was utterly ridiculous that
was honestly probably the acts biggest
blemish for me seeing as the plot hinges
on that mechanic for baby and Super
Saiyan 4 and finally the fight should
have ended 1 episodes sooner
should have ended right after herb
revealed himself to be inside baby that
was a great swerve in the height of the
fights action for me
the following episode just shows more
useless one-sided fighting on the site
of Goku and honestly really ruins the
fights memory and atmosphere in the end
however with that said despite these
drawbacks I think the baby arc of Dragon
Ball GT was very very fun and in a lot
of places well thought-out I can't wait
to see what the next arc has in store
don't forget to leave a like and
subscribe and I'll see you all in the
next video thank you so much for
watching
[Music]